NS
STRUCTOF LO
LINES IN UKRAINE
W VIDEO INTO
COMPLETELY RACE AC THE
UKRAINE HARNAS COMPROMISED, NEAY
5 BILLION GAON
FLOOD SORNNE E THE GREAT
SALT LAKE IN
SOLDRSBEG AWAY.HIS MENCHED RUSSN
DNIEPER DAMIS
RUSSIA HAS BEEN IN CONTR OSIDE,
ZAPORIZHZHIA WELIES ON THE TS RS
TONIGHT.MISI
BERATE
THE DAM ANDP FACILITIES BY THE
ISN ENVIRONMENTA
MB OF MASS DESTRUCTI.SAKE OF TH
AWAY WITCH TERROR.
>> RUSSI IT, BLAMING
THE UNIT STATES IS
INVEIGATING, IT SAYS,
INTOE. ZENIOR
HE SAID THE AT W T ANTICIPATED
COUNTEROFFENSIVEIC
ALDNIEPE
HERE'S ZELENSKYY'S ADV.N KHAN
RUSSIA IS TRYIO SUSPEND OUR
COROS
DIRECTION.
>> FRED PLEITGEN IS "OUTFRONT"
DED REGIONeporter: MASSEATER GA
IN RUSSIAN CONTROLLED TERRITORY
BOTH SHORESE
MIGHTY DNIEPERIV IMPACTING
AREAD.
E OUE'S IVE RESCUE EFFORT GOING
REL S ARE USING
HEAV AND BO GET ASNY PEOPLE OUE
R HER LIFE.OT SHE SAYS, ITR CAT,
WHUSE OF, THE R U  AND WHEREWI
THE AUTHORITIES HE SAY THE
EVACUATED HUNDREDS OPEROUGHO, A
KHSO WATER, HE SAYS
MINES, MINES ARE FG TO
HERED THIS DISTRICT IS
CONSLY
TWO POLICEMEN WERE INJUREDEVACU.
KYIV BLAMES MOSCOWLYOWIN THE DA
UKRAINIAES NSINAIL
E'CUBATTLEFIELS.Y THN OCCUPIERS
AGAIN
E CYNICISM WITH WHH RUSS TREATS
THE ST UKRAINIORCES HAVE BEEMAK
RLAGES O
NG-AWAITE UKRA
D THAT.
'S ARMY DENIES BLOWING UP
THE DAM, INSTEG E
UKRAINIANS.
AIMING TO PREVENT THE OFFENSIV
ATE
ON THEONE FRONT
LIE KYIV REGIME IT ACT OF SABOTR
RELIES ON PO CONNECTEDO NTE STRV
DANG, >> IT IS THEREFORE VITAL N
NOG Y RME ITS
SITUATN OUTHNGEROUS  THEXTREMELY
CONNUAINE W
NG.
ARE TWO THINAT OURRSEEE
AWARE OF.
ON T OTHER HAND, THO ARE RI EXTE
TER WENT U
CONSIDERABLY.
ANE G IS
RUSSIARYO IS
THERE IST SHEL
BELIEVE THAT MORE THAN A HOUSESN
>> FRED, T Y, KH THEAT ALDU HEAR
THUDS OFHELLING DISTANCE OF UKRT
NOW.
I ECOUR TIT
MORNING WHERE ES UKRAINE HAVE P
HAS BEUSSIANNTHS ISINGLE P DAM
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE IS THAT THI
THE N CAME FROWITHIN, T HAD TO .
E THRUHA
THEY WERE THE ONLYD ACTUAL THIHE
C GIVEN THA DO
ESS TO THIS Y NOW ANIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS TERRITORY  SETP A
EXIOCIAL THAT EVERYONE
T
ORFICIALAI
DAN
OFFICIALS DO SEE SIGNS THAT THE
-AEROFFENSE  IS BEGINNING.
VI T
AB5
N, DOES THE
LEAS PD HAVENGAGED IVENSEFINITET
COUNTEROFFVEHELPING WITH THE PEN
OF T COFFENS
UNCLEAR. WE NN CONFIRM
THAT THEY COULVE
DIREIO.
BUT E FA THAT IT DEFINITELY
DIVERTS EFFORTS FR TMITAHE HU,
BEING OVY THE MILITARY
PERSONNE SOUTH
NOW, THAT IS DEFINITELY N BEIRD
PART